[Music]
so today we're going to cancel randy
moss moss is a former nfl wide receiver
wide receiver and a current espn sports
analyst we already know that most espn
sports analysts are far left weirdos but
the other thing to understand is that
most espn sports analysts
are embarrassed about being espn sports
analysts they seem to think that it's
kind of silly and frivolous to simply
talk about sports every day and you can
decide whether you agree with their
self-assessment or not but their way of
dealing with this insecurity is to
pretend that they're part of some kind
of greater and more profound cultural
conversation
due both to their political slant and
this need to overcompensate
they're always eager to make mountains
out of mole hills they're always looking
for places where the events on the
football field might intersect with
larger societal issues
the problem for them
is that the two things rarely do
intersect which means that they have to
work a lot harder to draw the connection
and speaking of mole hills it was
revealed last week in a stunning and
earth-shattering expose in the wall
street journal
that current raiders head coach john
gruden sent an email 10 years ago where
he made fun of another guy for having
big lips
and the other guy's black which of
course makes it not only racist but a
hate crime of historic proportions
john gruden stands alongside history's
greatest monsters hitler polpot donald
trump all because he were marked on the
size of another guy's lips
now for a little background gruden was
himself a commentator on espn at the
time that this email was sent in 2011
he was upset about a lockout in the nfl
that was poised to short circuit the
upcoming season
and gruden put much of the blame for
whatever reason um on executive director
of the nfl players association demoris
smith
venting his frustration in a private
email gruden wrote quote
dumb morris smith has lips the size of
michelin tires
that was it
that's what he wrote
ten years later
and this one sentence has led to great
controversy and backlash and people
calling for him to be fired and
everything else
now gruden has of course apologized
publicly and profusely for making the
comment about the guy's lips he says
that he didn't mean it in a racist way
in fact he says that he meant that smith
has rubber lips hence the michelin
reference which is an expression that
means somebody is lying so he thought
that smith was lying about this whole
lockout situation
um gruden has issued several statements
assuring the public that he's not racist
that he doesn't have a quote racist bone
in his body
that he's deeply profoundly profusely
sorry for all the you know for all the
uh
millions of people who've been somehow
hurt by a mild insult he wrote in a
private email 10 years ago
he's said all this of course it doesn't
matter at all nobody cares about the
apology they still want him to be fired
for demoris smith's part he took a bold
and heroic stance when reached by the
wall street journal this is what this is
the statement that he gave he said quote
this is not the first racist comment
that i've heard and it probably will not
be the last
this is a thick-skinned job for someone
with dark skin just like it always has
been for many people who look like me
and work in corporate america you know
people are sometimes saying things
behind your back that are racist just
like you see people talk and write about
you using thinly coded and racist
language racism like this comes from the
fact that i'm at the same table as they
are and they don't think someone like
who looks like me belongs i'm sorry my
family has to see something like this
but i would rather they know
i will not let it define me
how inspiring
now if that were me
and the wall street journal contacted me
about an insult that some guy had said
about me to some other guy in an email
in the year 2011
my statement would have been something
like uh what
why are you asking me about this
he said my lips were big
in the year 2011.
um okay
and
that would have been my statement but
that's only because i'm an amateur
demoris smith is a professional he was
ready to milk this particular cow for
all it's worth and that brings us
finally to randy moss moss was part of
the sunday nfl countdown show on sunday
morning where typically they're supposed
to talk about the upcoming games and
give their mostly arbitrary predictions
for which team is going to win and how
many yards various players are going to
gain and so on
but this whole matter of the email and
the lips lipgate as i've come to to to
know it
provided the assembled cast with an
opportunity to have a very important
conversation they always want to have
very important conversations
and randy moss more than any of them
was ready for it listen to this
obviously there's going to be a lot of
emotional responses to this teddy i i
hear you saying basically if you were in
that locker room today you kind of just
put your head down and you think of him
as the leader in terms of the decision
maker but not necessarily a leader you
respect i'm curious from your
perspective randy if you were in that
locker room today would you be able to
play for him
you know to speaking of teddy teddy's
point you know
basically you hear us talk about we got
work to do we got a job to do and that's
to provide for our families and and and
teddy hit it right right on the head of
just putting your head down and going
playing football you know i i speak
about the game of football i fell in
love with the game of football sam at
six years old and
i get emotional talking about it because
of
situations like this
my civil rights were taken were were
kind of messed with in high school over
the color of my skin and now being able
to play 14 years in the national
football league
to have something like this of a leader
we talk about leadership we give guys
these big contracts
because they want to be able to lead 70
men coaches equipment staff and managers
to the number one goal and that's to win
the championship and for us to be moving
back and not forwarding 21st century
like i said man
national football league this hurts me
the clock is ticking man
it's a good thing i wasn't in the room
for that panel not that they would
invite me on a sunday
nfl countdown panel but how can you even
keep a straight face i would have to
interrupt and say dude are you what are
you are you crying
are you crying right now
no i didn't get confused by the way and
play a clip from another conversation i
know you might be wondering
you're looking at that and you're
listening to that and you're thinking
well hold on no this must be a
conversation from another time when
somebody shot randy moss's dog or
punched his grandma or caused him
offense or harm in some other
significant way that would explain why
he was so emotional
but no they're really just talking about
the email from 10 years ago about a
guy's lips and not even his own lips
randy moss is in tears he's actually
crying
because some guy wrote a private email
to some other guy making fun of a third
guy's lips
10 years ago
and to make this all the more grotesque
but also hilarious
moss says that he wants to move forward
and his way of moving forward is to have
a public meltdown over something someone
said 10 years ago
that's how we move forward is by is by
is is by sifting through
private emails
sent during the obama administration
that's how we move forward as a society
really
and this is supposed to be a football
pregame show
people are tuning in to watch guys
pummel each other at full speed and
cause traumatic brain injuries and the
lead-in act for that show features a man
crying about an insult that wasn't even
directed at him
but it's not over there are other people
on this panel and they all want to show
off their dramatic acting chops also
let's keep listening
i can play for you but i'd rather not
okay i'd rather not do it but if i have
to do it i will and it's just because i
have other people that i have to provide
for right but i'd rather not do it yeah
but it
we've done it before in different
situations we are all mentally tough
people in that locker room but it's
something you'd rather not do yeah so
this is what i think about it's like
randy's sitting up here feeling this way
from a distance
i can't imagine a guy in that locker
room today trying to play a football
game feeling that way with a heavy heart
how i don't know i don't know how what
max matt or rex i would love to hear
your perspective what should the nfl do
right now you see this response and you
guarantee there's there's a version of
this response in that locker room what
should they do how do you make this
right how does john gruden make this
right at this point or is it a lost
cause
i'm at a loss for solutions but i think
the the answer to that question probably
comes from somewhere inside that locker
room
see this is why i said
i don't want female football analysts
and i'm referring to all of them at the
table there
i have to remind you again they're still
talking about the lips
and and um
i i wonder if we were to search through
their emails from the last 10 years
what would we find
would we find things at least as
offensive and insulting as uh you know
making fun of a guy's lips
what will we find
why don't why don't they give us the
passwords to all their gmail why don't
they go come on the show next sunday
give us the passwords to their gmail
accounts let us let us go look at all of
the emails they've sent for the last 10
years
can we find something worse than that
while they're crying about an email like
i said 10 years ago
were they sending worse emails i bet you
they were
randy moss has been accused of domestic
violence in the past and arrested for
battery
has he been a total gentleman in his
private communications
i mean i i wonder what what emails and
text messages he has sent to and about
the women who have made these
accusations against him
i wonder
i wonder something else earlier this
year nba star kevin durant sent a whole
string of expletive-laden messages to
the actor michael rappaport
um and the whole what led to that
doesn't even matter
he but kevin durant an nba nba superstar
threatens violence
he uses anti-white slurs he uses
anti-gay slurs
and this were these were messages he
sent
to someone
in reference to them
this year not 10 years ago
were there any tearful segments on espn
about that
if i were to go back and look would i
find a whole panel of sports analysts
reduced to tears consoling each other
over the trauma that kevin durant's
words inflicted upon them
i don't think so what about randy moss
did he have anything to say about kevin
durant
again no
and that's because this is all a game
i mean randy moss doesn't play the game
of football anymore
but he does play this game
you know he's he has gone
from the game of football
to the victimhood olympics
and he has a man and he has gotten so
good and he was a great football player
no nothing could take that from him
and it turns out he is great at
victimhood olympics too
randy moss is the randy moss of the
victimhood olympics
when he has managed
to make himself the victim
of an email that someone said 10 years
ago making fun of another guy
incredible and yet even so i must say
that today randy moss is cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated